Today, we're in Shawnee,
Oklahoma,
where they've got some eagles,
hawks, even hummingbirds.
He's gonna do
what we call rousing.
It means he's very happy right
now, so he must like you two.
- Why have you never roused
for me?
- Sorry.
- Gav: Look at that.
So weird.
- Dan: Wow.
And action, hummingbirds.
- Go on, son.
- Gav: Whoa, look at that.
- Oh, whoa.
- Dan: Oh, he is just not
happy about it.
Gav: Dive-bombs him.
That was wicked.
I really like filming animals
at work.
I mean, it's just the best
subject for me to film.
It's always stressful though
because you never know
if a bird's gonna perform.
You can't exactly tell
an animal to do something
and expect it to do it.
A slow mo rouse.
You know, I love
depending on animals
to do what we want them to
exactly when we want
them to.
Maybe if we turn around,
pretend we're not looking.
( chuckles )
- Go on.
- Look at his feathers.
Gav: I got it.
It's funny how different birds
have different methods
of flying.
Like an eagle can just soar
and maybe flap once a minute
or something if it has to.
But then a hummingbird
to stay where it is
needs to flap however
many times it is a second.
Yeah, well we filmed both
on the Phantom,
so why don't we go over
to the screen and compare 'em.
Okay, so I brought up--
it's probably one of our
very first shots of the day.
But supposedly the hummingbird
beats its wings
the most times
in a real time second
on this clip.
So, what we'll do,
we'll count the wing beats
until it's displaying
one second.
I like that we have to have
that small of a unit
of time.
Yeah, I mean, you do.
It's slow mo footage.
- All right, ready.
- All right, count.
( music playing )
One.
That's two.
Yeah, now it's on three.
This is three right now.
- That was three.
- This is three, yeah.
Okay.
Now this is four.
Four.
We might have to speed this up.
( music playing )
Gav: All right,
that's one second.
- 48.
- Well, uh, it's sort of
47 and a half
'cause it's sort of
half way.
Oh, sorry, hold on.
Yeah, uh...
- There we go.
- That's right, you're not
getting all the credit.
( laughs )
Only 47 and a half?
In one real time second.
That is really fast.
It doesn't seem that amazing
when you're watching it
back on slow-mo.
I mean, are you saying
that our slow-mo made him
less impressive?
- Yeah.
- ( laughs )
- Yeah, exactly.
- How many flaps could
you do in one second?
- Three?
- Maybe?
- An entire flap?
- What does that look like?
( laughter )
Okay, this is good
information.
So now we know that.
Why don't we now compare
the footage
to the footage of
the hawk that we have.
We'll have to speed
this up
- to match the hawk.
- All right.
- Yup.
- That's two different
worlds right there.
- Yeah.
- ( laughs )
It's kind of unfair
because the hummingbird
is about the size
of that one's beak.
Yeah, you've got to remember
that this
is actually like this big.
Also, they completely flap
their wings in a different way.
Like the hawk bends
its wings halfway
and it'd be kind
of difficult.
That one just has
straight wings.
The hummingbird just
does this.
It looks like he's getting lift
on his backstroke, too.
Whereas this one,
he doesn't have to
worry about it.
- He's kind of just
enjoying the glide.
- Both of those can fly,
but they've got two completely
different ways of doing it.
I think we should learn
a little bit more.
All right.
Hey, Peter,
thanks for coming on.
Hey, thanks for having me.
It's great to be here.
Dan: So we're with
the hummingbird expert,
so, I don't know much
about birds.
I'm hoping you could
enlighten us.
- I'm happy to do it.
- Yeah.
So we've just counted 47 and
a half wing beats per second.
- I think we should round 'em
up, I think he got 48.
- He doesn't deserve it.
- All right, all right.
- He didn't work hard enough
for that.
So is that average,
or is it usually
they get more?
That's right about
in the middle of the range.
So normally, between about
40 and 60 beats--
strokes per second.
One other thing I noticed
is that it seemed like
they were getting lift
on their forward flap
and the back swing,
is that right?
Peter: They're the only
birds to do that.
Dan: The only birds to do it?
Peter: Yeah, and they do that
because they're able
to flip their hand over.
It's basically their wrist
going back and forth.
So it's able to get lift
in both directions
which is--
it still has the same stroke,
forward and backwards
that another bird does,
but it's flipping
and able to get lift
in both directions.
They're the only bird
I've seen where in real time
I can't always see the wing.
'Cause it just looks like--
Peter: Well, they're the fastest
stroke of any animal.
I also like the fact
that it's named after
what it sounds like.
There's not many birds
that-- coo-koo.
- ( laughs )
- A hummingbird...
hummingbird, sure.
I can't imagine
how tiring it would be
to be flapping your wings,
you know, 60 times a second,
'cause I, you know,
get on the couch and I get
hungry sometimes.
- ( laughs )
- Well, they eat a lot.
they eat half their
body weight each day.
They need a lot of energy.
Their metabolism
is just outrageous.
It's the fastest metabolism
of any creature or any animal.
And they're smart.
They can remember which flower
they were at
and which one had a lot of
nectar and which one didn't,
and they'll return to
the better flowers.
And they'll get
territorial about that.
They'll take their bill
and use it as a little spear.
They'll just stick ya.
Gav: Yeah, we saw in one of
the clips there was a dive-bomb
going on,
and the other bird had
to hop out of the way
pretty quick.
Dan: So once it dive-bombed it,
I was just wondering why
it was so territorial?
'Cause it seemed
there was loads of food.
Peter:
Yeah, there is loads of food,
but it turns out there's
sort of two ways
you can go about being
a hummingbird, right?
You can stay in one place
and protect your one
source of food.
Or you can fly
all over the place
and visit, like, one
or two thousand flowers maybe.
And it turns out
it's cheaper just to stay
in one place.
- ( laughs )
- You can save ten or twenty
percent of their
energy expenditure in a day
by protecting a place
instead of flying around.
It sounds like British
tourists on sun lounges.
- ( laughs ) Yeah.
- I parked it.
So even if they're
flapping their wings
you know, 60 times
a second, they're lazy.
( laughs )
They can't be bothered
to go to 2,000 flowers.
Well, thanks very much
for those amazing facts.
- That was great.
- That was great, yeah.
- Thanks a lot for coming.
- Thank you.
Okay, so we've done a comparison
between different bird wings,
but we also filmed the eye lid
of a golden eagle,
and I'd be interested
to see who blinks faster,
the eagle or Daniel.
We have a blinking
competition going on.
- You ever been in one?
They're brutal.
- I'm ready.
This might be the easiest thing
I've ever had to do for us.
I usually ask for a little bit
more of you,
but this one, all I need
you to do is blink.
Just stand there.
Okay, when you're ready
for me to blink.
- You just did.
- Dan: Oh.
( laughs )
I got it.
- That was it.
- All right, show's over, guys.
I feel like if I asked you
to blink,
you would do a very
unnatural blink.
- Dan: I'd be like--
- Gav: So I just got a blink.
Okay, I'm just gonna cue it up
and then we'll go
and compare the speed
to our eagle.
All right.
Okay, we have them cued up
right before the blink.
Place your bets.
Who's faster?
I'm the fastest blinker
in the west, so...
- Yeah?
- Dan: Yeah.
Okay, let's compare,
are you ready?
- Yes.
- Okay. Three, two, one, play.
- Oh, he smashed me.
- Gav: Wow.
Absolutely smashed me.
Gav: And I feel like you barely
completed the blink.
- Just finished.
- Your eyelids barely met.
You like mostly blinked.
Yeah, I already like
half blinked
and then mostly did it.
That's ridiculous.
Ah, it's just majestic
isn't it?
I mean, yeah, the way
my eyebrows are...
just so bushy and nice.
( laughs )
What?
Well, I've learned something.
Hopefully you learned
something, too.
Feel free to subscribe
to the Slow Mo Guys
and check out
other episodes from
"Planet Slow Mo."
- If I had to eat every
15 seconds I'd be so fat.
- ( laughs )